okay sounds good so so the next talk is
rachel lynde she's a professor at the
university of washington also down the
great amount of work on program
obfuscation and she'll tell us about
recent advances okay thank you very much
it's an interesting experience to
present over the Internet
thanks our start and the talk I prepared
relatively okay technically so we're
gonna go through and I will try to
monitor Q&A if I figure out how to so so
I'll do it and and if there are
questions I'll interrupt you okay okay
that's more convenient yeah all right so
um thanks very much Lucia whatõs
introduction so now I can go a little
bit faster in the introduction part yeah
so the goal here is program vestigation
and we would like to be able to
efficiently transform a program there
may contain a lot of valuable
information into another one that is
functionally equivalent that compute the
same function and now becomes
unintelligible and this transform
transformation is what we call the fast
culture and is we were interested in
building and obviously we won this of a
skater to be efficient in the size of
the original program and produce in the
first two the program that is
predominantly larger there has been a
lot of effort in formalizing what kind
of security or what does this
unintelligible word mean
and here we focus on a weak version of
it is called indistinguishability
investigation and what it require is
that if we had started with the tool
program that really computers in
function however implemented in very
different ways then we will like the
transform the programs to look
indistinguishable hard to tell apart so
in other words and what I'll guarantee
is that it were hide and implementation
difference for the same function and at
the first glance appears to be somewhat
of a weaker guarantee
and is another one with it intuitively
one to front of a SCADA program but the
upside is that because the security
guarantee is weaker there's no general
impossibility so we can potentially
build io for all polynomial sized
circuits and it turns out that even
though appears weaker it's actually not
actually weaker it's such a very very
powerful tool in cryptography so far
there has been a lot of work trying to
construct I'll very briefly most of them
are built on some sort of motive in your
map and you can think of them as a
generalization to PI linear map but it
allows you to a higher degree pairing so
the first generation or rely on Mata
linear map with very high degree pairing
and since then there has been a lot of
work trying to kind of reduce the degree
needed and in the second generation
where we reduce the degree needed using
randomized data encoding and we can
manage to drive the degree all the way
down to degree three in other words just
needing trial in your map a very very
important tool that started to appear is
the use of PRG with some simple
structure and in this second generation
the simple structure we want is the
locality of the PRG more recently that's
using a different type of approach using
homomorphic encryption we managed to
actually rely on only bilinear map with
just a blue tube and here we need a
different type of simple PRT in which we
call a low degree noise generator then i
were going to detail very quickly and
also together without w so this third
generation of using homomorphic
encryption is what i am going to focus
on in this talk and in the most recent
work we actually managed to show that
the low-degree noise generator is the
only simple PRG simple sort of pseudo
randomness generator that we need okay
so since all the other primitives
by linear map and lwe your publisher
familiar ways so let me just dive right
into this low degree noise generator
what is it with properties we want a
noise generator is an expanding function
over DP so it's an arithmetic function
we would like to expand a seed that is
of length n into an output R that is
polynomially longer think about this
into the 1.01 any n to the 1 plus
epsilon is enough we would like to have
really really small degree minimum
degree possible over CP but we also want
some structure one structure is that we
would like the output to be small here
by small and it remain polynomially
bounded as opposed to say smaller
comparing with the modulus P and the
reason that we want this output to be
small will become later in the talk and
this is because of constraints in
pairing groups in order to discrete
logarithm by force we will like the
output to be polynomially small so given
that the output is small we need to
think about what kind of security
property we have from such a small
output instead of asking for the outputs
to be pseudo-random all we need is some
hiding property intuitively it means
that this output are can hide even
smaller noise in upper bounded by some
bumping and our should reasonably
naturally be larger than B but still
pretty normal size more precisely we
would like to say that when R is added
with this noise e which is smaller then
I would like the if I look at each of
the coordinates say RI plus e I these
two distribution which is RI without any
I versus any I'm sure be close to each
other and this is one way to formalize
what it means for R + E to hide a
um some of you you might already be
thinking wait a second right it's very
yeah what question um so you want the RI
+ CI to simultaneously it says it's sort
of a it's not a coordinate wise and if
indistinguishability you really want all
the RI plus CI to look like alright yes
exactly I really want or the RI plus E I
to look like R so what so my correctly I
should rather say that the distribution
of our class E and the distribution of
our are close yeah right
but I cannot illustrate high dimensions
so in the slide that we only talk about
one coordinate yeah but that's a very
good point it's a bit confusing okay so
for some of you that you may already be
thinking that wait a second if our our
eyes are predominantly small there's no
way that it can really hide AI even if
AI is just zero one this is for people
working with lattices we all know that
this much noise needs to be super for
normally large in order to completely
hide the noise so therefore we cannot
hope that our class e completely Heine
and at the best we can hope that a
partially Heidi what does a partially
mean this is a very good question and in
the literature we have had a two
different formalization one is called
pseudo flawed smudging the other is
called the perturbation resilience and
let me give you the definition for
perturbation resilience what this
requires is that these two distributions
do not need to be negligibly close but
rather we just want to distinguish an
advantage to be bounded away from one so
as you can see that we actually allow
quite a relaxed margin that we know that
distinguishing advantages at least some
inverse polynomial but we only require
it to be one to be smaller than one
minus some inverse polynomial okay so
this is what we want we want the output
of the noise generator to be small and
we want them to have partial hiding
property so now the next crucial
question is how low degree these
generators can be
we know that degree one is impossible
because we can solve linear system using
Gaussian domination
so therefore what about the degree two
unfortunately so far we have no
candidate with degree two a very natural
attempt everybody would want to try is
to take some random the route to
multivariate polynomials
here I write them as a system as a sum
of quadratic monomials and in order to
make sure that the output is small we
will evaluate those pranaam use over the
reals so that it does not create a
cancellation mod P because once it
creates cancellation we have no way of
controlling the output of being small
and to make sure that it does not create
cancellation will choose all the
coefficients of each of the monomial
together with the input from some small
distribution you can think about as more
Gaussian or small uniform this will
guarantee that the output is also small
and much smaller than the modulus and
therefore there's no cancellation
unfortunately exactly because the fact
that there is no cancellation this kind
of degree to reopen o'neill's
can be attacked using sum of square
attacks so so the natural so this seems
to suggest that the minimal degree needs
to be three and indeed if we have a
random degree three polynomial they can
be shown to be resistant resistant to
two somewhat square attacks but we're
greedy we don't want degree three so we
managed to get degree two point five
what is degree two point five I'm not
inventing your math but let me just
explain so we will indeed start with a
degree three multivariate pre Gnomeo and
now we want to somehow compress down is
degree over the P how by hiding one of
those input vector U as lwe noise
so hiding in the other debris noise
means that we're creating this oil
debris samples of the form a a as prime
plus U and U is exactly used as a debris
noise so if I write it just as a
rewriting of the equations we know that
U equals to C times s whereas is minus s
prime comma one nothing has happened so
far and let's say that how we can
compute this degree three print on your
chi now because u equals to CS I can do
a change of variable and now can you see
my cursor okay looks good yeah I can do
a change of variable now this function G
I can rewrite it as a different approach
or mule which acts on C and also only
tensor s comma W the nice part is that I
can you this C which is out of resample
and something in the public and we can
record the public seat of this noise
generator and the rest and there must be
hidden is what we call the privacy life
you look at what is the degree of the
noise generator technically it's still
debris three over the public seed and
the private seat
however we see that the degree on the
privacy now is only two and the degree
on the public seed is one and this is
what we mean by degree two point five
because ultimately what we care about is
the degree on the private part so Rachel
this you could have done anyway by just
kind of your pre-processing a bunch of
variables so you're increasing the
number of variables so this you could
have done you know you can you can do it
at any polynomial right I can do it with
any polynomial indeed I can generalize
to an editable a Gnomeo
actually there is a limit I can only
generalize to a constant degree
polynomial so to summarize so far when
we get in this degree 2.5 noise
generator
the degree on the public the degree on
the private seat is 2 and the point of 5
are sort of signals the computation on
the public part so the security we want
as we said is that given the our debris
samples we would like the output of the
pre nominal which is R plus e to
partially hide e and this assumption can
be further decomposed into two
assumptions which is just to help us to
understand what this assumption is
asking for the first unnecessary part is
that we want the random degree three
polynomial to have this partial hiding
property if there's without those
additional or debris samples that
encodes the first vector u so in other
words I just won the output of G degree
three polynomial G + E to partially
heidi and this we can actually show that
is resistant to SOS with attacks because
of the degree and the next assumption is
that how does the debris sample come
into play we would like to make sure
that given the our debris samples
encoding the first vector you in some
sense that because of RWE this u is a
hidden so the assumption that I give you
out every sample with a consistent you
used in the evaluation of the polynomial
it's indistinguishable from I give you
out every sample with independent u
Prime so if we put those two assumptions
together it will naturally imply the
partial hiding property so raychel this
polynomial is degree two point five
polynomial is now not over the rails
it's oh it's much more people on your
right some other people now know exactly
where a polynomial over the rails you
would be able to break it essentially
because the number of variables is too
few is that that right or if it's a
degree two polynomial then and it's over
the reals an SOS attacker can come to
play however when this
you're variable to make it into degree
to ascension we did a change of variable
and when this change of variable
they're introduced to cancellation and
then that's why it's not clear anymore
than whether so I said would apply so
there's one more question in the Q&A if
you press the button at the bottom
without reaching for all debris based
the things would reduce in the degree
using real analyzation based a technique
work this seems somewhat similar
okay so real in irritation is something
that we always need to be careful about
what happens here is that we still have
sort of even if you can't number of
variables in the private seed alone and
there's actually roughly earn variables
and number of outputs is into the one
point or one so you cannot directly
relate your eyes because this there is
still too many variables I hope this
answers the question okay so we're gonna
continue so as Madonna has observed the
data there's nothing special about
degree three we can actually generalize
to degree constant of renewals and but
for the purpose of this talk we can just
think about the degree three version so
the theorem that we have now is that we
can't rebuild I using by linear map lwe
together with such degree 2.5 noise
generator more accurately we actually
use the tools to build a functional
encryption for P directly which as
previous work has shown is known as
equivalent to IO up to some security
laws just to mention again and previous
works were also need to rely on block
local PR G's in this theorem and the
latest work covered of it so there are
two important tools in the theorem one
is what we call special homomorphic
encoding and the other is what we call
casually hiding
no encryption that ever introduced them
in the rest of the talk okay so let's
now start to see how this theorem is
proven we said that the goal that we
want to build is a functional encryption
which also gives you i/o and roughly
what function encryption allows us to do
is to give you the cipher text for
inputs and give out the partial
functional secret key for functions and
the decryption will reveal exactly the
output of the function evaluated on the
encrypted input and the privacy
guarantee is that only this improve
these outputs are reviewed the magic of
functional encryption why it's so
powerful is because then you can give
out any number of cipher tags in any
number of functions secretly for
different functions and the derive or
the possible combination of outputs for
different FM f and x and the privacy
still guarantees that it will reveal
only these different combination of
outputs since we are at functional
encryption and the one of the important
role we look at is what we call
partially highly functional encryption
let me just give you this definitely
tell you what this primitive is right
away so partially hiding functional
encryption adds a public input to the
ciphertext now the ciphertext is created
encoding a primate into the X and the
public input a and the rest is more or
less the same we would like the
correctness to reveal both the outputs
and also the public input and the
privacy guarantees should mean that only
this information are revealed so the
only difference between Concha hiding
functional encryption and the classical
function functional encryption is the
presence of some public oh sorry it is
the presence of the public input so one
question is and why do we why do we
formalize this and the reason that we
can see that it is very
useful for evaluating these degree 2.05
noise generator whose the seed contains
the public part and the private part and
the nice part is that because we do not
require hiding of the public input we
can actually handle those functions that
computes up to and see one computation
on the public input and whereas in the
functional encryption world where
everything needs to be hidden we're
still gathering functional encryption
for NC one is still a very hard task and
precisely the task that we're dealing
with now ok so keep this 2 in mind let's
come back to the task of constructing my
own it turns out that I and the for
constructing my L we just need a weaker
variant of this emotional encryption
which we were only ever without a single
secret key but you need to think about
this secretly as producing as including
a function that has a very long output
instead of a single output and here on
obviously we will still allow lots of
different cyberattacks for different
inputs and the privacy make sure that
only the right output is revealed so one
more requirement in order to gather i/o
is that we want to we will need to make
sure that the size of the ciphertext
which usually we think about as a
pre-nominal in the length of the input
and here we would like the size of the
ciphertext to be and to allow it to also
scale somewhat with the size of the
function but as long as it's not
linearly scaling instead it is a sub
linear in the size of the function and
this is what we call the compactness
requirement so for the rest of the talk
we're gonna try to construct this is
single key functional encryption with
compactness and most of the time you can
ignore the fact that there are lots of
different ciphertext and we can just
think about single ciphertext our not
explicitly address compactness and by
the constructions compact pretty easy to
observe Oh
all right so our starting point is the
similarity and the difference between
the functional encryption and
homomorphic encryption homomorphic
encryption can also allow us to do a
computation on some encrypted input and
it produces a ciphertext of the output
we're going to call this alpha
ciphertext HC HC TF the difference is
that here on Muffy encryption it really
reveals no information about X or about
the output Y whereas in functional
encryption we actually want to get one
therefore the most important difference
if we want to build functional
encryption far more Fink encryption is
to decrypt in a private way so what
about trying to decrypt using some
simple functional encryption scheme
we're gonna use a simple encryption
scheme and include in the functional
encryption ciphertext ciphertex of this
simple EFI scheme encrypting some input
and in the secret key the secret key of
the simple EFI scheme of some function
age so that when we decrypted it were
exactly decrypt the output ciphertext HC
TF and the reveal why we would like to
make sure that the proper security
property of the functional encryption
scheme will make sure that only Y is
revealed and this relates to this need
for ensuring integrity in the sense that
only the right output ciphertext for the
legitimate function f for which a secure
key has been issued can be decrypted in
addition that is seems to be somewhat
weird that I am using a functional
encryption scheme to construct a
functional encryption scheme to make
sure that this paradigm is not kind of
doing nothing we want to make sure that
the function that in the simple Fe
evaluates in order to decrypt
should be much
and the function f that we are actually
computing M only construct F is an
arbitrary pronominal time function and H
is going to be something much simpler
alright so let's go ahead and try to
figure out what kind of function in the
inputs will allow us to do this also
forgot to say that ideally we want it to
be so simple that ultimately we can
implement this simple F 3 using standard
assumption all right so we want this
function encryption to help us to
decrypt so that means that inside it we
wanted to compute the decryption
function so for most of the form of
encryption decryption is basic linear
operation on the secret key and the
output ciphertext followed by a
surrogate function problem is that this
is not simple this is actually an c1
function because of the threshold so one
first to third is that we want H to be
simple so what about it just not doing
the threshold this would correspond into
doing only half decryption which only
does the linear computation and what did
this world linear computation will give
us is going to be the output plus the
noise so this brought us a problem which
is that output plus the noise and the
noise may be leaking a lot of sensitive
information and indeed this noise in al
qussair attacks can depend on the secret
key of the homomorphic encryption as
well as the encrypted input so to help
bridge to remedy for the privacy our
next authorities what about using our
noise generator to generate some as much
noise to hide a so now we're computing
instead on the half decryption plus the
noise generation
now privacy come back again because the
noise generator has this partial hiding
property that were help has to hide it
and for the purpose of this talk we were
gonna ignore the fact that the partial
partial hiding is imperfect and I will
only mention you towards the end but for
now let's think about it really
perfectly Heidi a nice part is that we
have not increased the complexity of
each by much right now it is just a
degree 2.5 function the next problem we
need to solve is the integrity in fact
in order to decrypt a doubtful
ciphertext it seems that so far how can
this function H take the outputs effort
X as the input unless we put it actually
in the corresponding cipher text but and
the encryption time we actually don't
know what is F and we cannot even create
this opposite vertex so to solve the
integrity problem we can use the special
form of encoding as a tool or partial
highly functional encryption and let me
tell you about only the solution using
special homophony encoding here so what
is this special form of encoding we are
all very familiar with homology
encryption it allows us to evaluate the
function of homophily and get the
encryption of outputs the nice part is
that it has very simple decryption
nearly linear we saw that a linear
operation will already give us the
output perturbed with some noise the
special harm of a encoding actually has
two parts separates the homomorphic
evaluation into two parts so first it
starts with some public parameter and
that is a share in different instances
of this homomorphic encoding and
encryption will depend on both the
secret key as well as the public
parameter and this parameter a are
really just LW matrices lots of them
now homologate Federation where
evaluates all the cyberattacks and
produces some kind of we can also call
it the ciphertext of the output but
there is also on public evaluation part
which depends only on the public
parameter and produces a matrix called
AF and the nice part is that in the
decryption equation now change to this
form and the unique thing is that now
the secret key does not need to directly
operate with alpha ciphertext anymore
instead the secret key acts together
with the public matrix AF and now
computed output subtract with the
opposite vertex gives the output plus e
so this seems to be a rather rather
minor change but if we gave that I did a
little bit closely we'll see its power
so let me call this the output of the
linear have a half linear decryption SF
and we observe that if I add 2 SF some
smart noise are what the equals true is
the with rearranging the equation the
hcg have plus a plus a plus y plus E
Plus R and that this right-hand side
tells us that really only information
conveying is why why because the outpost
advertised can be computed publicly a
plus R is now smudged therefore E is a
hidden and hence the only information
reveal this Y in other words you can
really view sf+ are a sort of functional
key for F that reveals only the output
of F a catch is here that in order to
enable this kind of decryption equation
the public parameter or the LW matrices
a are we used everywhere and has the
secret key must be some port for
each ciphertex of freshly putting these
two together an alternative view of this
special form of encoding is that it's
actually one ciphertext functional
encryption with a very very simple key
generation so with this we see that and
now we know what you give to the
function H this function each just need
to compute the linear decryption acting
on the secret key and AF which is a
public plus the noise generator to
produce this marshal noise R and since
there how what did it produce if you
since the hammam are opposed after tax
it can be publicly computed from this
output we can recover the output Y ok
and now ok so this solves our integrity
problem next what are those tools that
we need and can we have them
well one tool that we need is the
special form of a encryption and
actually we show that the we can get
special form of encryption with this
special decryption equation or the way
for or P from other blue and the other
and previously there has been some
construction but to know the handle
pre-nominal or polynomial computation
and the next tool that we need is how to
implement this simple functional
encryption which now is evaluating a
degree 2.5 function and this can be
computed using exactly our partially
hiding functional encryption and then we
show that this tool can be implemented
using by linear map handling up to and
see one public computation and the
degree to private computation and one
catch with this construction is that the
output will be computed in the exponent
of the target group and therefore if we
really want to obtain the output of
function each which is going to be
computed in the exponent of the target
group we need to do this real logarithm
by brute force and to do that we really
need both T plus R to be small in order
to make that feasible and this is why
that we want a noise generator to have
polynomial size pretty nominal magnitude
output I mean on how am i doing in time
- four minutes Rachel so we should we
should drive up okay you didn't stop me
so but okay okay so I think I have
already give out the construction and
I've had some slides for how to build a
special form of encryption well only
thing that I want to say is that it's
basically following from predicate
encryption and existing protocol
encryption book would give us this tool
and we are not going to go through the
slides for them and the jumping directly
to the concluding slide what we have
seen for now is that this is the degree
two point five generator special harm of
encryption and partially highly
functional encryption to build a
functional encryption with weak security
why weak security which I sort of hide
it on the rag is that this noise
generator actually only have partial
hiding property and because of the
partial hiding that it's not complete
hiding it leads to the functional
encryption with only weak security
and in order to get a full functional
encryption enhance I own we were needed
to do harness amplification and this is
what I usually is going to talk about
next and I give you sort of the rough
guideline on how to obtain the ability
to 0.5 noise generator but the noggin
your very specific candidate but in the
later talk that Amit is going to talk
about what are the concrete candidates
and some of the crypt analysis and they
tell can I ask a quick question can you
go back can you go back a couple of
slides which one the one way you say
that you do this in the exponent it was
just two slides ago I think yeah yeah
yeah it says yes this this one so it
says at with outputs this Astrix this
with outputs in the exponent of the
target group so sure as far as I
understand you can actually be code it
right
I mean it's polynomially bounded yes
because you can actually compute the
Hammad
right so you're doing the modulus
reduction outside right
you
that's something
next
okay
you do it with the you know you do it
directly without all the structure of
fhe they have much more structure around
than you did know so the structure of
the fhe is something that both
approaches need so even in my in my talk
I described that the theorem was that
noisy linear Fe plus this kind of
special effects will give IO so Rachel
talked more about the structured fhe I
did not talk about it at all but it's
also something I mean both approaches
need that in my talking where you see
that this function age 30 was trying to
compute is doing linear have linear
decryption plus the noise generator so
you I understand the directors view and
then you can sort of mute add as doing a
linear computation plus noise so that
sort of fits into what should I say